تم تأكيد الفصل المادي
في الساعة 105 مساءً بالتوقيت المركزي حيث كانت المحطة
تطير 259 ميلاً قانونياً قبل
تنفيذ تسلسل الطيران ،
سنراقب تنين الطاقم
طوال تسلسل المغادرة حيث
يشق طريقه من
قهوة المسعى
ونحن  المتابعة مع
نسخ طاقم
Dragon  التصميم أثناء المهمة
ليس بالضرورة في هذه المرحلة الزمنية ،
ولكن يبدو نوعًا من السخف أن
نراهم يطفوون هناك ، لذلك أردت فقط
أن أشير إلى هؤلاء من
أجل الوعي ،
وآمل أن نحصل على الكثير من هذه كيت
بينما نشق طريقنا حول  المحطة مرة أخرى
نحن في بعض
فترات التسليم الأطول الآن ولكن قد نراها
على الشاشة التي تعد مرة أخرى
عرضًا مباشرًا لمحاولة التنين الخام أه
غادر لمدة 20  دقائق ، إنها
حوالي 20 دقيقة ترانزيت أه للوصول إلى ذلك
التالي أه تلك النقطة التالية وهي بشكل
أساسي الفرق هنا في التحكم في المهمة ،
لقد كان هوثورن مشغولاً خلال
الأيام العديدة الماضية ، ولدينا فرصة
واضحة لأننا أزلنا من الإرساء لدينا
فرصة
للتناثر  للأعضاء بما في ذلك
شين كيمبرو وميجان مكارثر الذين
أعتقد أنهم ما زالوا يرتدون
بدلات دخول قاذفة سبيس إكس